surrealist master Salvador Dali is now
at the center of a bizarre paternity
lawsuit Spanish judge yesterday ordered
the iconic artists remains to be dug up
this is decades after his death now a
woman who claims to be his daughter from
an affair wants to see if Dolly's DNA is
a match Elizabeth Palmer is in London
with the case that could be worth
millions of dollars Elizabeth good
morning good morning well of course
we'll never know what dolly himself
might have thought of this bizarre
surrealist you could say court order
would he have been horrified or maybe
delighted after all he made a career as
the great master of surrealism in
twentieth-century art and grew famous
and rich in 1934 he married gala a
Russian teacher and their relationship
to had it's surreal side they never had
children gala had other lovers and for
years
they lived apart with dolly only
visiting upon written invitation dolly
lived and breathed surrealism the basis
of his ideas are as he puts it
cauliflowers and rhinoceros horn but as
he told mike wallace in a 1958 interview
his devotion to gala was in fact very
real they'll be never met love I think
why not repeal our album a tarot card
reader who claims dolly is her father
after an affair with her mother who was
a nanny near Dolly's home but he made on
me I want this exhumation to tell me who
I am she told Spanish TV and to bring
satisfaction at last to my mother I will
insists her claim isn't about Dolly's
estate which is worth hundreds of
millions of dollars at auction
his paintings fetched stratospheric
prices this portrait of Paul Ella warred
went for more than twenty million
dollars I'm their sculpture - and a
famous museum dedicated to the man who
today we might call the grandfather of
performance so what to make of a Belles
claim in spite of a slew of beautiful
models and studio assistants surreal as
it sounds Dali always vowed he was a
hundred percent faithful now science
could disprove that but it may not get a
chance because the dahlia state says
it's going to fight this exclamation
gale
alright Elizabeth thank you police says
he was a hundred percent faithful but
most men who were accused of being
cheater cheater pumpkin eater 'he's
always tell the truth about that we'll
see how this alter nobody interesting to
see what happened an affair with the
nanny that's so unusual I can't think of
another example but oh wait maybe okay
we'll be following that one bring you a
update as soon as we get it believe me
very curious